SECURING OUR BORDERS, FIGHTING
BACK AGAINST RADICAL ISLAMISTS,
REBUILDING THE MILITARY.
FORMER DEPUTY ASSISTANT TO THE
PRESIDENT, FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR
AND SEBASTIAN GORKA, FORMER
ARKANSAS GOVERNOR FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR MIKE HUCKABEE.
HE WILL BE THE HEADLINE, HANNITY
SAYS MEDIA IS LIKE DRUG ADDICTS.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT?
I DO.
BECAUSE THEY WAKE UP EVERY DAY
AND THEY'VE GOT TO HATE THIS
PRESIDENT AND THEY HAVE IGNORED
SO MUCH, WHAT DO YOU THINK IS
GOING ON?
>> SEAN, HAPPY NEW YEAR, THAT
WAS QUITE THE MONOLOGUE.
THE CNN SEGMENTS, I THINK THEY
ARE HANDING AROUND A CRACK PIPE
OF TERM HATRED.
THE ANALOGY IS PERFECT.
THEY NEED THAT DOPAMINE DUMP
BECAUSE NONE OF IT IS LOGICAL,
AS YOU'VE SAID FOR THE LAST 11
MONTHS THEY HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO
IT'S THE STOCK MARKET, THE JOBS,
THE SECURING THE BORDER, THE
DEFEATING ISIS.
NONE OF IT MATTERS TO THEM.
IT'S ALL OBSESSIVE
PSYCHOLOGICALLY OBSESSIVE HATRED
OF A MAN WHO THEY DON'T
UNDERSTAND, AND ALL THE PEOPLE
HAPPENED ON NOVEMBER THE EIGHTH,
THAT'S WHY THEY HATRED CONTINUES
TO BUILD.
JUST MAKE THEMSELVES IRRELEVANT,
AND THAT'S GREAT FOR FOX AND
THAT'S GREAT FOR ALL PATRIOTS.
>> Sean: I HAVE TO IMAGINE
IT'S A LITTLE MORE PERSONAL FOR
YOU WHEN THE MEDIA IS SITTING
THERE ATTACKING YOUR OWN
DAUGHTER AND QUESTIONING WHETHER
OR NOT SHE TOLD THE TRUTH ABOUT
MAKING A PIE?
AND THEY WANT PROOF THAT SHE
MADE A PIE.
HAVE NOW BECOME.
>> FIRST OF ALL, I CAN TELL YOU
SHE MADE THE PIE, BECAUSE SHE
MADE UP FOR US A CHRISTMAS, SO
THAT I CAN CONFIRM.
>> Sean: I'M GLAD IT WASN'T
THERE BECAUSE I WAS ON A DIET.
BUT I HAVE TO DISAGREE WITH BOTH
YOU AND DR. GORKA.
HERE'S THE REASON.
YOU SAID THAT THE MEDIA ARE LIKE
DRUG ADDICTS, AND I THINK THAT'S
I'VE KNOWN A LOT OF DRUG
ADDICTS, SEAN.
AND A LOT OF THEM ACTUALLY GO
INTO REHAB AND THEY GET BETTER.
THE PRESS NEVER GETS BETTER,
THEY KEEP GETTING WORSE.
THEY BECOME MORE OBSESSED WITH
THE DESTRUCTION OF DONALD TRUMP
THAN THEY ARE WITH THE BUILDING
UP OF AMERICA.
THIS IS A PRESIDENT WHO HAS HAD
A REMARKABLE YEAR.
RANCH, BUT THE TRUTH IS OUR
ECONOMY IS BETTER, OUR SECURITY
IS BETTER, WE ARE TRUSTED BY
AT THE MIDDLE EAST IS RAPIDLY
CHANGING IN A POSITIVE WAY.
HIS HAD THE GUTS TO STAND UP FOR
THE URANIAN PEOPLE AGAINST THEIR
AUTOCRATIC TOTALITARIAN BRUTAL
TERRORISTIC GOVERNMENT AND THEYC
TERRORISTIC GOVERNMENT AND THEYN
TERRORISTIC GOVERNMENT AND THEYT
TERRORISTIC GOVERNMENT AND THEYS
TERRORISTIC GOVERNMENT AND THEYE
TERRORISTIC GOVERNMENT AND THEYA
TERRORISTIC GOVERNMENT AND THEYY
TERRORISTIC GOVERNMENT AND THEYO
TERRORISTIC GOVERNMENT AND THEYF
TERRORISTIC GOVERNMENT AND THEYT
TERRORISTIC GOVERNMENT AND THEYA
TERRORISTIC GOVERNMENT AND THEY.
DRUG ADDICTS SOMETIMES HAVE GOOD
DAYS.
>> Sean: HOW DID THEY IGNORE
ALL OF THIS TRUTH ABOUT
LAWBREAKING AND CORRUPTION?
HOW DO THEY NOT TELL ANY GOOD
HOW IS IT POSSIBLE THAT THEY ARE
SO MYOPIC THAT THERE'S NOBODY IN
CHARGE SAYING GUYS, WE ARE A
LITTLE BIT BIASED HERE AND IT'S
REALLY OBVIOUS.
THIS IS NOW A CRISIS OF
CONFIDENCE IN WHAT WE DO.
>> I THINK THE ANSWER IS VERY
SIMPLE.
I THINK YOU ALLUDED TO IT IN
FOR THESE INDIVIDUALS.
IT'S NO LONGER ABOUT REALLY
PERFORMING A PUBLIC SERVICE.
THEY CAN MAKE THE RIGHT
JUDGMENTS, ESPECIALLY WHEN IT
COMES TO AN ELECTION.
THE MEDIA HAS BECOME LIKE THE
OBAMA WHITE HOUSE.
NARRATIVE IS EVERYTHING.
REMEMBER THAT DEDICATION TO
HILLARY'S MASTERS THESIS.
IF SHE SAID THE FIGHT IS
EVERYTHING.
IT'S NOT ABOUT THE TRUTH, IT'S
THIS PRESIDENT DOES, LIKE HIS
FAMILY DOES, THEN YOU ARE THE
PROBLEM.
REMEMBER, LEADERSHIP HAS BEEN
REASSERTED WHETHER IT'S WITH
LITTLE KIM AND NORTH KOREA,
WHETHER IT'S IN NATO, THE
REASSERTED BY DONALD J. TRUMP
AND THEY CAN'T STAND IT BECAUSE
FOR THEM WE ARE THE PROBLEM,
AMERICA IS THE PROBLEM.
>> Sean: WHAT'S YOUR TAKE,
GOVERNOR, ON WHAT HAPPENED
>> IT'S DISAPPOINTING IN PART
BECAUSE JUST A FEW DAYS AGO
HE'S CRAZY, HE'S A WILD MAN.
SUDDENLY THIS GUY MICHAEL WOLFF
BUT I MEAN THE ONLY GIG HE'S GOT
CAN'T GET ENOUGH OF THEMSELVES.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THIS, THERE
ARE TWO THINGS YOU GIVE TO
SOMEONE WHEN YOU WERE HIRED IN A
POLITICAL CONTEXT.
YOU GIVE THEM LOYALTY AND YOU
GIVE THEM CONFIDENTIALITY.
THOSE ARE THE TWO VIRTUES THAT
ARE MORE IMPORTANT THAN ANYTHING
ELSE YOU CAN BRING.
AND IF YOU SEE HOW MANY PEOPLE
THEY'VE HAD INTEGRITY WHETHER
IT'S SEAN SPICER,
REINCE PRIEBUS, SEBASTIAN GORKA.
THERE HAVE BEEN A NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WHO CAME OUT -- AND THEY
DIDN'T GO OUT AND TRASH THE
PRESIDENT OR THE OTHER PEOPLE
THEY WORKED WITH AT THE
WHITE HOUSE.
STEVE BANNON SAID ALL ALONG THAT
THE ENTIRE RUSSIA INVESTIGATION
WAS A FARCE.
THOSE ARE HIS WORDS.
A COMPLETE FARCE AND THERE WAS
NO COLLUSION.
>> Sean: DR. GORKA, LET ME GET
YOUR TAKE ON THIS.
>> THE STORY CHANGE.
IT WASN'T DONALD TRUMP.
IT WASN'T DONALD TRUMP'S.
>> I WILL LET STEVE TALK FOR
HIMSELF.
HE'S A BIG BOY.
BUT I KNOW THAT MIKE WOLF IS A
HACK.
HIS LAST BOOK, 13 PEOPLE
COMPLAINED ABOUT MISQUOTING AND
HAVING THEIR QUOTES --
>> Sean: SO YOU SUSPECT HE WAS
I'VE NEVER SAID THAT.
MAN IS PART OF HIS BOOK PROJECT.
NEWSPAPER.
ALL I KNOW IS THERE IS NO
GERRIT, DON JR. ARE PATRIOTS.
>> Sean: MOVED OUT BANNON SAID
IT?
>> I WASN'T THERE AND IT DOESN'T
SOUND LIKE -- HE WOULDN'T DO IT